Die Wasserstraßen von Venedig in
majestätischer Ruhe
– ein äußerst seltener Anblick.
Die Gondolieri kommen langsam zurück
in die Kanäle der Stadt,
aber noch sind die Fahrgäste rar.
Auf dem Markusplatz, wo es
normalerweise von Touristen nur so wimmelt,
laufen die Geschäfte schleppend.
Mit der Coronakrise kam das Leben in
der Stadt regelrecht zum Stillstand.
Nun öffnet sich Venedig
langsam wieder für Besucher.
Aber nicht jeder freut sich
auf die Rückkehr der Massen.
Jane Da Mosto sieht dies als eine
Möglichkeit, die Zukunft zu verändern.
Die Aktivistin setzt sich für
nachhaltigen Tourismus ein,
einen, der die Zukunft der
Stadt nicht aufs Spiel setzt.
Das Problem mit Venedig ist,
dass es ein extrem fragiles,
empfindliches System ist.
Man kann nicht alles damit machen.
Man muss sehr vorsichtig damit umgehen.
Sonst bleibt in Zukunft
nichts mehr übrig von Venedig.
Wir müssen verantwortlich mit dem
Vermächtnis von Venedig umgehen
und daran denken, was es uns gegeben hat.
Andere Menschen haben auch
das Recht, das zu bekommen.
Sie erzählt uns,
Venedig habe einen einzigartigen Lebensstil
und der drohe zu verschwinden.
Jane Da Mosto möchte, dass Touristen
wieder am Leben in der Stadt teilnehmen,
Zeit in den Restaurants
und Museen verbringen
und nicht in wenigen Stunden hindurcheilen.
Obwohl die letzten Monate ohne
Gäste für ihn sehr schwer waren,
stellt sich auch Nicolo Bortolato für
seine Stadt eine andere Zukunft vor.
Der Hotelier möchte seinen
Gästen ein entschleunigtes,
ein, wie er sagt, „wirklich
venezianisches“ Erlebnis bieten.
Die Touristenströme müsse man mit strenger
Regulierung in den Griff bekommen.
Wenn an manchen Tagen viel zu viele
Menschen hier rumlaufen,
dann deshalb, weil die Events in der
Stadt falsch organisiert werden.
Wie kann man die Regatta im Canale Grande
zur gleichen Zeit austragen wie das Filmfest
oder die Neueröffnung eines Museums?
Ich denke, wir sollten den
Tourismus auf das ganze Jahr verteilen
und nicht nur auf sechs Monate.
Venedig muss seinen
Tourismus neu definieren.
Das findet auch die
Tourismusbeauftragte der Stadt.
Aber anstelle von drastischen
Maßnahmen möchte sie
lieber erst mal weiter Fakten sammeln.
Das ist kein Museum.
Wir legen keine Obergrenze fest.
Kennen Sie eine Stadt in der Welt,
die das macht?
Na, ich glaube nicht.
Viele, viele Menschen sprechen
über die Zahl der Touristen:
Es sind 50 Millionen,
30 Millionen und so weiter.
Aber das ist nicht wahr.
Ich will sie zählen.
Ich werde wissen, wie viele
Menschen jeden Tag kommen.
In Europa werden die Reisebeschränkungen
allmählich aufgehoben.
Viel Zeit haben die
Venezianer also nicht mehr,
um zu entscheiden, wie die Zukunft
ihrer Stadt aussehen soll.